the closest I'll ever get to an Oscar
speech can you hear me I'm really tall
so I feel like it's not good is can you
hear me now
alright why that guy in the corner I
want to help me that's perfect thank you
thank you so much okay
my name is Cora Thomas and I'm so
excited to be here tonight and I'm
closing the show Oh a lot of pressure so
I won't I did not memorize because I my
memory is that of a fruit pie so I have
to read off of this paper but I will try
to not do it as much as I think I need
to okay so my my overarching theme for
my story a common theme but an important
one in today's world is when one door
closes another door opens so I'll take
you back to New York City almost 12
years ago I was 22 years old a year out
of graduating from Parsons school design
one job under my belt which I had quit
promptly quit because of a lesson
pleasant boss I decided like any 22 year
old with a chip on her shoulder no money
and very little experience to start my
own company because that seemed smart
this wasn't totally out of the blue
while at Parsons I knew in my senior
year that accessories was really where
my passion lead the margins were great
and I love the size
there was no sighs you know there was
just want to fit on your ear it didn't
and
and I loved it and I love that you can
take a pair of earrings and like throw
it on with a pair of jeans and she sure
did
totally change her outfit it was it's
it's really what was my passion and
still it so anyways here I was at 22
starting a jewelry line I was making the
wax carvings which I'd never done before
I was sourcing my materials in New York
producing it in New York and to be very
clear I really had no experience doing
this I barely even like had sketch
jewelry prior to this and well besides
her that like odd pair of earrings that
you make at your local food store in
high school that you think are really
cool until you lose them like two days
later that's about the extent of my
experience but anyways I was just doing
it and the one thing I did come to
realize very quickly was that I loved
having my own company and I loved having
full creative control of something I was
lucky to get some press behind the
company I was written about an owl and
Harper's Bazaar Lucky Magazine and
clearly in my mind I was bound for
incredible overnight success like this
this is it at 22 I was gonna make a
million dollars you know making jewelry
out of my kitchen in the East Village
okay yeah the dreams of your you well
okay so as you can imagine where this
story is going it totally fell apart I
didn't know how to run a business and
just plain and simple I just needed more
experience so I packed it up embarrassed
and frustrated and just decided okay I
have to move on so that door was shut
but I realized how much I love designing
jewelry and knew it's where my focus
should lay my next opportunity came when
I landed a job at j.crew a new door had
opened this is my first real experience
in jewelry on the large scale and I
can't stress enough how important and
influential that experience would prove
to be I learned how to merchandise a
line my sense of color
silhouette grew and I built invaluable
production connections most of which I
still used today so realizing that had I
not attempted that first company and I
wouldn't have been in that position and
which essentially completely expanded my
professional career so over the next few
years
I'd left j.crew I was freelancing for
some different brands designing jewelry
and doing some concept work and I was
feeling really stifled I still have
designing but something just didn't feel
great 'van uh for me even though I was
in like such a creative field in the
midst of all of this I started dating
someone a photographer adora I probably
shouldn't have opened and gone through
but I did so you live in you learn
anyway is this mr. geographer on a
really tight budget for shoot as if I
would cater lunch for the following day
as my friends know some of who are here
tonight I love to cook it is my second
love and also very creative so I said
yes of course and completely unknowingly
walked through a new door for the next
two years I ran Cory Thomas catering I
know and hater hater shoots for Teen
Vogue and Zara Harper's Bazaar Neiman
Marcus it was it was such an
unbelievably exhausting experience but
it was so it was so rewarding seeing
people's happy faces when you know they
piled up a plate of my food on a shoot
and just seemed happy for the first time
in their day was so was so great and it
was the same feeling that I got when I
saw someone trying a piece of my jewelry
and had a smile on their face so but I
see
it's kind of a trend in my in my life
that around the two-year mark I realized
like what was I doing getting up at 5:00
in the morning to prep breakfast for a
7:00 a.m. shoot this is crazy
I'll never forget running down Wall
Street in New York and 9:00 a.m.
dodging businessmen trying to get back
to set holding a tray a fennel sausage
I'm thinking to myself I can't do this
long term like this is crazy
and two things like two years ago I was
designing chandelier earrings and now
I'm like hoofing it in the financial
district with like a hot tray of meat
this is not this is not for me but it
was great and an experience nonetheless
it was a true labor of love but again
not sustainable for my future but it's
solidified that I how fulfilled I felt
being in full creative control of
something and owning my own business so
I jump back into jewelry design working
for a club monaco which eventually led
to me going back to j-cruise other brand
made well and at the time I knew the
creative director from my time at j.crew
so I got the job designing their jewelry
which again was such an amazing
experience and just really solidified
with accessories is where was what I
wanted to do so two years it made well
that two year itch starts again
definitely a trend for me and in the
fall of 2015
I made the tough decision to quit my job
and leave New York after 12 years
so I sorry I lost my place
oh and move without a job without an
apartment without much besides great
friends to help cushion any falls to
move to California I just have this
feeling that if I moved something great
would come of it
so much of California spoke to me I'd
offer great weather
a great burgeoning design scene and most
importantly spaced and if anyone has
lived in New York for longer than a
month
they know what I'm talking about but
also emotional space which we talk a lot
about in California so it was it was in
this new environment that I was able to
finally define what I wanted to do I
took all the pieces from my past all the
conflicts and success all the things
that made me tick and laid out my dream
scenario I started to start a company
that would design and produce
accessories for many different brands
constantly challenging myself being able
to work with a range of brands and
appeal to different audiences stretch my
creativity keep me on my toes and keep
my career feeling fresh so Cory Thomas
design started in my tiny apartment in
Venice and now it is in a beautiful
office instead of Monaco with three
hopefully seem to be for employees and
five brands under its belt and it's the
most rewarding feeling that I've most
rewarding experience I've ever felt in
my life in addition to my company with a
very good friend of mine we launched an
accessories brand called berrineau which
this past fall which has been also just
such an amazing outlet for both of us
who also have full-time jobs on on this
well we have full-time jobs and we do
this on the side so it's crazy but it's
great and lastly be really sweet for me
to say to him but anyways on a very
personal note on top of all the
happiness to success that California has
brought me I also met my husband here a
year ago so that was really really
special a little cherry on top so what I
hope you can take away from my story is
that don't be worried about not staying
on track run down the street with those
sausages
do anything you can walk through every
door that opens and no failure is ever
really a failure it is just a tool to
help you further define what you love
Thanks